o psol de 21 extremos um vídeo um pouco
diferente eu vou ensinar hoje como fazer
duas coisas utilizando uma caneta 3d
qual que no entanto essa marca em um
telão
aí eu não vou fazer isso disse má e
publicitários vocês quiserem comprar uma
caneta é só ir em um dos sites que
vendem coisas na internet escrever em
caneta 3d que uma possível vários
modelos há vários presos no início as
canetas eram bem caras só que atualmente
os modelos estão mais aperfeiçoados mais
finos e bem mais barato
uma coisa que vocês têm que ter atenção
quando forem comprar uma é o preço do
filamento porque se forem como eu gasto
muito filamento é uma coisa bastante
cientes destas coisas em 3d
então vejam quanto é que vai custar o
filamento vejam quanto vai custar a
caneta e pronto
o mais importante é mesmo o flamengo por
comprar a caneta uma vez é e quem
comprar um filamento depois disso fazer
este vídeo uma equipe do outro se vocês
gostarem idéia um feedback positivo eu
posso continuar a fazer coisas assim em
3d e posso fazer o que vocês deixaram
nos comentários faz um panda faz o urso
celular agora todos os animais faz uma
casa então vocês podem tirar os
comentários de hu no próximo vídeo possa
tentar fazer o que vocês pedirem eu fiz
aqui um marco e um chapéu é uma coisa
bastante 110 e sem grande por isso é pra
fazer é só usar modos resultado final
fica sempre um bom ok
uma coisa que o deter foi necessário
daqui de natal era ter posto um led
nutron o tronco ficou assim o cu então
se eu tivesse posto num leve e acho que
fica bonito à luz a seguir assim pelo
meio dos bonequinhos mas ainda vou fazer
isso e ficar bacana e eu posso estar
assim um vídeo bem pequenino facebook
para vocês verem como é que ficou com a
boca bacana aqui na minha mesa uma vez
que estamos a chegar aí ao natal
aí vocês podem fazer várias partes de um
projeto de atendimento do projeto fazem
diferente parte podem juntar depois de
usando o filamento como pagamento das
partes queremos usar uma cola usam um
filamento para juntar é de frente para
te perguntarem o que vocês tiverem
momento
é e só estamos a chegar ao fim agora só
colar essa parte de cima assim uma
icônica é bem bacana eu acho
aí pronto só soubemos do fim eu espero
que tenham gostado se vocês quiserem que
eu faça mais vídeos começam a deixar os
comentários e estava com o carro